- Not one drop of my self worth depends
on your acceptance of me.
It's work when they say that
the dictionary's the only place
you see success before work
and that's alphabetical.
I was ready to
do myself in.
I just couldn't handle
the pressure anymore.
From day one, we need how
to play every kind of music.
Our entire business is
all based on two things,
a great song and a great story.
- He's an American record
producer, composer, musician,
and entertainment executive.
His career spans six decades
in the entertainment industry
and he's been nominated for
a record 79 Grammy awards.
Time magazine listed him as one
of the most influential jazz
musicians of the 20th Century.
He's Quincy Jones and here's
my take on his top ten rules
for success.
Rule number one is my personal favorite,
and make sure to stick
around all the way to the end
for some special bonus clips.
- Number one is to know who
you are and learning to love
who you are.
'Cause you can't love anybody else
if you don't love yourself.
Ray Charles and I used to
say, every day in Seattle,
not one drop of my self worth
depends on your acceptance
of me.
Every day, that was the deal
with racism and everything,
because we don't want an
external force defining
who the hell you are.
- [Interviewer] Where
have you gone, to improve
your arranging skills, as an arranger?
- (laughs) work and study, man.
Work and study.
I did that a long time ago.
I put 28 years in my core skill
and orchestration,
counter point, everything.
Music is always left and right
brain, intellect and emotion,
and you've got to work to
keep the science going.
You don't work to keep the science going,
you can't support the emotion.
A million guys come and tell me,
"man, if I could play piano,
"I could be better than Herby Hancock."
I say, yeah, but you
ain't going to be better
than Herby Hancock because
you haven't worked.
But you have to work.
It's work man.
They say that the dictionary's
the only place you see
success before work and
that's alphabetical.
In school, we were
exposed to march music and classical music
and semi-classical music.
To make a living, you
had to play schottische
and all those things, so it
was always the full range
of music around.
I remember once Ray Charles said to me,
we were trying to put a bee-bop feeling
in the schottische one time
and he says, "no, you just
put your soul into the music
"you're playing and
let it be a schottische
and it'll be okay."
I never forgot that.
- When Quincy Jones was
stranded in Europe, he realized
the importance of being a
good business man as well
as being a good musician.
He had to really look at
every aspect of the business
to try to get home.
This is my responsibility.
I got him over here, I can get him back.
- I was ready to
do myself in.
I just couldn't handle
the pressure anymore
because it was performing,
and the payrolls,
and the book and everything else.
I think when people think
about taking their life,
it's just about 15 minutes peace,
just to get some rest for awhile.
It's amazing how it works because
a whole series of mistakes, at one point,
people start to call experience.
Oh, he's very experienced in that.
That means you've had a
chance to mess up a lot.
That's great, because if
you don't take any chances,
you're not going to make
any mistakes, you know.
My father said to us
every day of our lives,
"once a task is just begun,
never leave it 'til it's done,
"be the labor great or small,
do it well or not at all."
Every day of our lives he said that.
He would never let us half step.
That I learned from him
and I treasure that though,
'cause he didn't believe
in doing anything half way.
- What advice do you have for the future
of making great records as a producer?
- Know what you're doing.
Study everything.
Study music.
I'm hearing some funny stuff
now that drives me crazy.
I'll talk to some of the producers today.
We were doing an amazing project
in Morocco last year.
We had all of the number one
singers in the Arab Spring,
Libya, Egypt, Jordan,
Aleppo, Damascus, everywhere.
We were recording over there
and I'm calling on names
over there and I said,
"do you read music?"
He said, "yeah, I used to, but I forgot."
Give me a break man, you don't
forget how to read music.
Man, you have to understand,
to put the work in
to learn the science, man.
You do.
You can't play a trumpet
if you don't know how to--
it's a science, the armistice,
the diaphragmatic breathing,
there's a lot of secrets with
everything you attempt to do.
Retrograde, inverting, counter point.
There's only 12 notes,
man, so you can figure out
what you have to do to get your own sound.
You have to do that through
rhythm, melody and harmony,
and you have to do a lot of
research to figure that out.
You have to know what's going on.
You have to understand, I
don't know a Bravelle and
Oldenburg and Basie
and Duke and Bo Diddley
and Melle Mel and Ludacris
and Drake and all of them.
Come on man, it's doing
your homework, man.
That's all I can say.
Prepare yourself, 'cause my
thing was, my biggest fear,
and I don't play with that word at all,
was to get great opportunity
that I'm not prepared for.
When Frank Sinatra called
me, man, I was ready for him.
I'm telling you.
And he tested me.
I'm telling you, Ray Charles
too, 'cause those guys
are rough man.
Billy Eckstine, Ray
Charles, Frank Sinatra,
they will kick your booty.
He'd say to me, we were
doing an arrangement
at Capital Studios, he'd
say, "Q, that first 8
"was a little dense."
So I say, no problem man
and I put all the horns,
the trumpets and the (mumbles) out,
transfer the saxophones
to the alto flutes,
stuff like, let's go.
He was testing me.
He only did it three times
and after that, he said,
"he knows what he's doing."
I was ready for it and
that's the biggest compliment
and accomplishment you
can have in your life,
is to say, I've go my stuff together.
I got my (bleep) together.
You have to have it together man.
(audience applauding)
You do.
- Let me ask you at creativity
then, and the diversity
that is Quincy Jones, because
I'm a kid of the 1980s,
so I know Quincy Jones, the
famous guy, the hit maker,
the pop wizard, the R&B soul guy.
You were a serious jazz
guy through the 50s.
I mean, you were on tour
with Lionel Hampton--
- No, no, no, understand
man, from day one,
we knew how to play every kind of music,
Sousa, Debussy, Schottische,
for Bar-mitzvahs,
rhythm and blues, everything.
We played everything, man.
I got a lot of, this is when I started
doing Michael Jackson.
I didn't have to learn
anything to do Michael.
I mean, I've been doing that all my life.
- That's my question though.
Is the guy who toured with
Count Basie or did arrangements
for Count Basie or Gene
Krupa, Sarah Vaughan--
- Everybody.
- That's the same guy who can
produce hip hop or pop music?
- Bubba, we were doing it all our lives.
Nadia Boulanger said,
"Quincy, God gave us 12 notes,
"the Bach, Brahams,
Beethoven, Bo Diddley, Basie,
"Bird, all use the same 12 notes."
"Until he gives us 13, I want
you to know what everybody
"did with 12."
I studied hard for 28 years, man,
and for seven decades, we
never stopped, you know.
We tried to play like Miles, tried to play
like Charlie Parker, like (mumbles)
and when you come out of that,
there's 10 different people
and your personality is going to finally,
not transcend that but morph
into its own personality
because it is a personality.
If you have traveled the
roads of all the great people,
but I think that happens with anything.
If it's a camera man,
you know, you look at
(mumbles), whatever,
all your favorite people
and just deal with just the best.
Or like classical composers
or whatever and people
that deal with drama, you know
with the elements of drama,
they all do it a different way.
Jump into it.
Jump all over it.
I'm serious.
Don't be bashful.
Jump into it.
Try to copy it, just like it is.
You can't do this on a professional level,
I mean in training your
mind to think on that level,
the highest level, go with
everybody from Johnny Williams
to Goldsmith to Alan Sylvestre,
Stanley Clark, everybody.
I have seven kids.
I have six daughters, 21 to 16,
that's why I don't have any hair.
(audience laughing)
And one son,
but my part of the tough love
is to tell them, the first thing they have
to know is know who you are.
Because a lot of people
don't know who they are.
And that's very difficult, but
that's the first challenge,
I think, is to know who you are.
If it's 70/30, work on it.
At the 30%, stop whining and move on.
Then, after you know who
you are, love who you are.
That's the first two steps.
(audience applauding)
Mantra to my children.
'Cause you're on your way
once you know who you are
and love who you are.
You're on the way, because if
you don't love who you are,
you're in trouble.
Always be true to yourself, baby.
Our entire business is
all based on two things,
a great song and a great story.
Film, television, if you
don't have that story,
nothing else matters.
You don't call anybody
else, or direct anybody.
The same with a song, great song can make
the worst singer in the world a star.
But a bad song, the three
best singers in the world
can not save it.
And that's the bottom line man.
- [Male] If you are not
working as a musician
until the later years of your life--
- It doesn't matter man.
At 60 you can start, man.
Nadia Boulanger told me that.
She said, "you can become an
attorney at 60 years old."
Man, you do whatever you feel like doing,
if you're willing to put
your mindset behind it,
the passion, and the work.
Anything, anytime in life.
(audience applauding)
70 years old.
I mean, I feel like I'm just
starting man, I really do.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I made this video because
Ari Gabriel asked me to.
So if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want
me to profile next, leave
it in the comments below
and I'll see what I can do.
I also would love to know
which of Quincy's top ten rules
had the biggest impact on you and why.
Leave it in the comments.
I will join in the discussion.
Lastly, wanted to give a
quick shout out to Mark Drager
from Phanta Media.
Mark, thank you so much
for buying one of my books.
It means a lot to me.
For those of you watching,
if you want a chance
at a shout out in a future
video, make sure to pick up
a copy of the book and
email in your receipt
so we can keep track.
Thank you so much for watching.
Continue to believe, or
whatever your one word is
and I'll see you soon.
- It starts with a human being you know.
Nadia Boulanger said that to me every day.
"Quincy, your music can never
be more or less than you are
"as a human being."
That's what it's about.
You can have all that
science and technique
and everything else.
If you don't have a life
and love and live and give
and stuff like that, you
have nothing to say, you know
to share, you have
nothing to share, to give,
and she's right, you know.
Man, I have lived man.
I did my best.
After Ray Charles, are you kidding?
Basie, Miles,
Sinatra, please.
Sinatra used to tell us every
night we got off the stand,
to live every day like
it's the last, and one day,
you'll be right.
(laughing)